To better understand the components of a data model,
let's first talk about what not to do when creating your data model.
I call this the uni-table.
If you're coming from an Excel background,
your first instinct when modeling data is probably going to be to
create an extremely wide table with all the aggregatable fields,
and all of the descriptive fields mushed together.
For example, here, amount is an aggregatable field,
we could aggregate the amount by getting a sum of the total number of apples sold,
which in this example would be two.
In contrast, variety is a descriptive field,
we can't add Gala and Fuji,
rather, these fields help us describe the other data.
For example, they allow us to know that of the two apples sold,
one was a Gala and one was a Fuji.
It's likely that your data didn't all come as a single big table like this.
But instead, you piece together your mega table using
one or more look-ups so that all the values you would need would be on the relevant rows.
In a small dataset,
you can get away with this,
but as the dataset grows over time,
it will become impossible to manage.
Having everything in a single uni-table is inefficient.
Again, what we mean by everything is that you've got
both your aggregatable and descriptive data in the same table.
This can work okay for small amounts of data,
but it gets increasingly efficient as the data grows.
I learned this the hard way during the first few months I was using Power BI,
my report could handle a month or two of data,
but it started to wheeze and freeze once I added several years of data.
I ran to IT thinking my computer was broken, where in fact,
I was just being very inefficient with the tools I had available.
What's the problem? Why do we lose efficiency
when we have our descriptive and aggregatable fields all mushed together.
The problem is repeat data.
Your goal when creating a data model is really just to minimize
that repeat data and make the structure of it as efficient as possible.
If we go back to our example,
we can see that we have multiple purchases that
all have the exact same descriptive information.
For instance, here are Fuji apples with the same PLU code.
This is because all of these rows are for sales where customers bought the same product.
Or if we look at the dates,
we can see that a lot of these sales happen on only two dates,
which all have the exact same data for month and year.
This is a lot of repeat data in our model.
As the dataset grows,
this is only going to get worse.